[Music]
and in road rage news submitted by Bree
a ball breaks out on the highway after a
white couple cut off a Latino family you
haven't done that in a while I don't
know why the race has anything to do
with the road rage
well I cut off all races it does have to
do with it because in the original
headline it says that this white couple
cut off this Latino family and called
them [ __ ] so they made it a baby that
makes sense
Peter never offended me [ __ ] love
rice and beans that's my chair someone
cut you off and called you a bean again
and then you're [ __ ] being alert lot
of trial wife they were like you [ __ ]
pretty
I like [ __ ] you you know you mean sit
behind the words
yeah even [ __ ] never got to me I've
never understood why didn't [ __ ]
there's the Rita the river yeah it's
some Mexican yeah we had to cross the
river together I thought it was a sweaty
but really childish insole that's really
don't cut deep what's another one I
[Applause]
don't care if you say [ __ ] to me but
[ __ ] speak is that does that hurt when
you said that because I never heard
speak for Hispanic yeah I've heard of it
but I haven't ever be called that like
I've been called wet bag and be no
Pilate ah hurt me what's that like
nopales cactus which we eat yeah but
then it's more for like the indigenous I
don't know people yeah so they're
calling you like Indian Indian I don't
know just the way it was said it'll mean
there's a lot of like racist turns that
you wouldn't even know we're racist
Indian giver
is a racist time yeah and doesn't even
make sense because they say like if you
give somebody something you take your
bats bat-ray it's rude
correct
yeah but they lost the war so we get to
call where everyone Eskimo huh that's
like a not a very hilarious and it's
because their rivals called them that
like as a derogatory so then when I
guess like why people were like oh what
is that tribe called and they're like oh
they're Eskimos or something I find
really um interesting that it's very
offensive and I understand why it's
offensive it's because of the intention
put behind it but exact I don't know
Japanese yeah can't be Jack it's more
like it's more like the historical tie
to that word like the words I get it
colored people yes like there's nothing
wrong with the word it's just a
historical usage of the word jungle
bunny jungle buddy what's that one cuz I
find like people jungle bunny well I
mean that sounds kind of cute I mean why
do call me that when I was young I'd
beat his ass
what does it mean I don't even know that
I know is disrespectful I said I love
Beach OS whatever there's gonna be a
best friend you try to close the door
but the door didn't close all the way
that's a jungle bunny yeah you guys
heard Daigo touchable rochonc yes we saw
economy cost somebody a [ __ ] bastard
yes yeah I don't know what it means but
I've heard it because of the movies
paddy wagon is a derogatory time what's
that paddy wagon like you know please
have it
apparently Irish people used to drink a
bunch of Asians just put them in the
thing and every call it up it's like aim
toward Irish people what is it I call
that paddy was an actual wagon no like
there was I guess and they would you try
they were just round them up
and there was just the guy go that's the
paddy wagon and it would be Irish people
Papi's planning it wrong but if you look
it up there so if you guys heard [ __ ]
yeah what was what is what is it it's
Italian oh they call them wops I don't
know why right like I when you watch
those like mafia movies they're like oh
he's a [ __ ] people don't get no bad for
white trash my trash is just straight to
the point white trash like there's no
having a we between the line there's is
my family for 10 years of my childhood
had a double-wide trailer parked in the
front lawn with white trash
oh yeah was [ __ ] growing around it and
stuff hey that's white trash redneck
those are good those are good sister
[ __ ] back to the storm watch the fight
so we are gonna watch yes
yeah a guy with intent to [ __ ] kick
someone's ass and not do [ __ ] I think
everyone lost that fight no Mexicans won
that they showed up with what did they
expect was it just a shouting match like
I'm gonna walk up to this car like I'm
gonna beat their ass and go what are you
doing maybe you can explain that Steve I
don't know what go what goes on um but
it is very common here like for white
people to come up aggressively oh yeah
but then not get violent yeah
on behalf of all white people so often
do it ambassador please teach us cowards
are just cowards I mean you you just you
just you're [ __ ] angry and then you
you don't have anything to do and they
work hours with the brave swagger cuz
they were walking up as if something was
gonna bad done this before you grew up
unchecked yeah it's and it's been cool
this whole time they were gonna
intimidate people so what happened
before they pulled over is that the
white couple was trying to cut the
Latino family off on the freeway on the
118th that is here in California but I
don't know where like really legal
driving maneuver by the way no but it's
very illegal I don't even know where the
118 is it's probably some like mess area
is 180 right would we're like oh that's
like that yeah no you stop it on a team
before I don't know if you like
everything was cool and tonight's had
been it I never like oh they activated
[ __ ] so they were trying to cut them off
and that's when they said [ __ ] no they
were trying to cut them off
and from like I don't know exactly what
happened after that moment but that's
when Latino family started calling the
cops
and then the white couple they pulled
over and then they came out and they
were talking [ __ ] to them and then
that's when the white couple was that
they ended up saying like all you [ __ ]
[ __ ] or whatever and then just
filming the whole time you was filming
us in the exciting two minutes ago yeah
you know family's like kids or whatever
all stupid yeah that's when the the
parents the Latino parents were like oh
you want to call me a [ __ ] and they
started beating on this not you know the
Mexican dude had no confidence in the
way in their white guys hands he came
out in flip-flops
yo kicked his ass find someone in
flip-flops yeah cuz I be second guess
this whole exposure I always think about
that too I'm like I'm like man some [ __ ]
went down right now cuz I'm wearing
flip-flops um I couldn't do anything I
couldn't run out we'll never leave the
house in flip-flops because of that
reason no I never travel I never know
what's gonna happen I don't just be a
terrorist situation whatever so I never
ever travel on a plane with flip-flops
always in shoes ready to run I've never
won a pair flip-flops in my life that's
why I just train my feet up on the
streets I don't know man is this I'll be
on the beach with Air Force One
I might go a different way I do the same
thing but that's because sandals are so
uncomfortable for me I wear sneakers
maybe - I've never seen you wear doing
yeah sneakers all the time yeah they're
just not comfortable why my feet are too
big and it's just annoying and they
slide around too much and found the
right pair of sandals maybe heaven thank
you what which type of sandals have you
tried Oh shitty ones the thong one I
mean I think he's here she'd be like
he's only bought two dollar ones from
Walmart like a thong one yeah I had one
life if you don't get the right ones
though they [ __ ] rub out this area
right in a [ __ ] hurts yeah yeah try
those and I tried those [ __ ] dad ones
when they have two straps a cold
terrible look terrible not just looking
but feeling the tried the the slip on
these looks like yeah those oh I tried
that yeah pretty comfy dad sucks no yeah
Casey hates those too cuz as he walks he
likes laid off trying to be bare few it
yeah I think that like slippers are
terrible for your feet as a whole I
think so when you're walking ideally no
support but for houses only I love
sandal they're not for outdoor use
I never want to see another grown man's
toes I just never mmm whatever I see
guys assemble some always display if
there wasn't [ __ ] and piss on the ground
finish for women and semen ma just be
like why the toe though are you ever
Beach bro do be the [ __ ] to argue me
I have my person pedicure like a year
and a half ago
do you like feet on women do you like
women's feet mm-hmm also that's why I
like it no I know exactly
no but I just I guess the reason why
whenever I see a dudes beat I'm just
like or toes I'm just like cuz I would
never have my toes I don't [ __ ] is your
toes out for ya my no well you see it as
like it's your dick is out yeah it's a
sexual dick he's like hey bro can you
cover your feet up please so you make me
uncomfortable just be like why am I
seeing your toes oh no no you have to
dig deep into why it makes you invisible
why this is happening to you they make
you uncomfortable man feet is [ __ ]
[ __ ] up though yeah
and their big [ __ ] toenail and then
the fact that their feet is all white
and crusty yeah a lot going on pumice
stone those things I've been training my
feet training yeah but turning my feet
to be this way yeah natural feet got a
lot of calories what if you got a penny
I do get pedicures with it every once in
a while yeah he's only done it once our
whole 10 years together every once in a
while like I said why would you want to
file down all the good stuff yeah I
built this up I built this up I can walk
this is why he's doing it is when we're
trying to cuddle and then we're trying
to play footsies on like what the [ __ ]
you're cutting up my [ __ ] feet that's
embarrassing you use this side this side
for battle so wait sexually you're in
defeat I mean listen tell you my mom
before yeah good for you have you ever
had a chick part of feet together no of
course yeah yeah there's a lot of people
like never just doing they're drilling
those feet I saw one last night with a
girl what guys sitting like go [ __ ]
wrapped around like this and started
jacking them all on their feet yeah
don't touch my dick what you see what's
wrong with me all right
I run barefoot you run barefoot well you
ever have a chick fee to make your
Mouse's oh I don't have the chicken
finger bang your mouth no what the [ __ ]
you're missing I did
your mouth of course that's why I can
come so uptight this is weird girls
trying to stick their finger in my okay
okay
I'd bomb it just put your toes in there
not your toesies not the fingers not for
everybody
[Music]